every time you think why it would work
you've come up with a reason both of why
that does not well no that's not a
reason why the purge wouldn't work it's
the reason why being an outlaw during
the purge wouldn't work because someone
would just kill you and then they would
go about their energy look like
eventually that's sure you're not gonna
be like guys even though the law doesn't
count right now this is against the law
you know like everyone's gonna be like
shut up yeah I wonder who that guy is in
the group like the guy who's like whoa
whoa too far oh my god whoa within
reason guy ha even even me we work with
these people you think we want to call
my mother oh my god i think i will just
cuz I'm so disgusted by you bunch yeah
there's that cell phone that i got from
that guy I killed yeah I hope he's still
got minutes yeah does he have my mom's
contact this [ __ ] as my mom is
contacted for me now I'm glad I killed
it hello i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
welcome two reasons to see we give you
reason to see and not to see The Lone
Ranger so why don't you and I hang out
Kemosabe
reason to see number one Johnny Depp
Kemosabe I would like miso soup please
dad that's Japanese yeah that is not
Indian at all he's funny in it but
honestly at times it was just like
watching indian Jack Sparrow in a way
just because he is sort of like a
central character who's also kind of a
side character I don't know I mean I i
liked the subtle differences of his you
know Native American thing Johnny Depp
used to do like serious [ __ ] movies
what happened I just became guy who's
always like hmm yeah well i guess the
similarity that Jack Sparrow would be in
the sort of buggy-eyed thing more he is
always like observing is that in a lot
of his characters now I always enjoy it
for some reason the event like even in
Dark Shadows I was like this is still
pretty fun he's definitely how Johnny
Depp would play at Indian I thought that
him as the indian guy was a little bit
weird i was so aware it was Johnny Depp
it felt like the first performance
problem watching Johnny Depp plate what
Johnny Depp doesn't it felt a little
sticky to me but it's like really good
stick there there was a time like back
then before like I think before Pirates
of the Caribbean where he would just
transform into roles even if Charlie in
the Chocolate Factory you stop thinking
about Johnny Depp sometimes but even at
that point you sort of work this also is
a script that does take time to stop and
have him say something you know silly
Tonto is not exactly the kind of
character who it is just part of their
being to make jokes I I don't feel but
noodles I mean I'm not a lone ranger
experts you know so maybe that's how the
show was yeah it sort of felt a little
bit like television comedy humor to me
with the way how he reacts his stuff cuz
he's kind of a quirky indian guy hmm you
know which makes them kind of cool yeah
which makes it [ __ ] awesome which
makes you realize how much I love the
character right now this very big reason
to see number two Armie Hammer I didn't
remember who Armie Hammer was until like
I saw his face and I was like oh he's
the twins from the social network that
is true yet yeah he's cool in the movie
I
I was as he has a cool name that well
what's his name his name's armie hammer
Oh his name is his a visit with the
character day you know as names like
John something armie hammer sounds a
little goofy to me armed with a hammer
well most people think of Armand Hammer
but for some reason I don't I just think
of some kind of cool super curbs really
it sounds like a cheesy superhero name
Armie Hammer I don't get it sounds
cheesy and sounds cool to me shut up I
think of a dork I think of something
cool but old-timey this guy yes this
mother [ __ ] over here now you crazy son
of a [ __ ] I'm just waiting for you to
go full denier what's the matter with
you huh it's like halfway I'm kind of
channeling my George senior from
arrested development right now yeah I
was going a little bit mixed with my
dinner okay Joe he says like if Jeffrey
Tambor and robert de niro had a love
child yeah can you imagine oh my god
high-concept plot you did it Jerry we
have read save the cat and we are
applying it that actually sounds like a
gripping LGBT drama yeah that sounds
like a good movie i watch when i go to
gate movies on netflix like half of it
will be like junior with arnold
schwarzenegger and danny devito and then
the other half will be like Kramer vs
Kramer and the finale will be like the
movie splice so armie hammer yeah yeah I
thought he was really cool in this movie
especially love the scenes with him and
Johnny Depp pay attention to those best
moments in the movie ya know the way
they play off each other and their
dynamics are really fun to watch and you
know that's where the movie shines the
most yeah that's um is that as funny as
this when it just seems that it's best
like they're acting together is
brilliant I wish they capitalized more
on it there was something missing and I
felt like we could have had a more
emotional connection to the movie if we
focus more on that relationship with
them stronger you know I mean the only
thing I would say about the Lone Ranger
as a character is you could have maybe
used more a bit longer of a stretch
where he is like fully realized like
yeah he is the lone ray
now and he's gonna do his thing armie
hammer it was perfectly cast because he
has like that old school American spirit
about him you know you you kind of
reminded me of like a Superman in a wet
it's got a good voice he does have a
good voice yeah if that voice had a
penis it does yeah I suppose he is like
a uvula okay we're cutting that part
reason is see number three the loves I
laugh surprisingly a lot in this film
not a lot I wasn't laughing throughout
yeah a lot I comedy but it's certainly
funnier than I expected it to be cuz the
humor it comes from within the
characters so there's a there's a sense
of humor about the film but if you're
right it's not a comedy every now and
again they'll say something that feels
like a goofy script moment but for the
most part yeah the comedy does sort of
come off the characters and how they
play off each other because they are an
unlikely pair especially you know the
Lone Ranger and Tonto and at least you
know you hear about blockbusters now
they suck all the time and it's cool to
see a movie that you know technically
it's like striving to be a blockbuster
thinking there's characterization in
here there's a health characterization
you know it's about these two guys who
really have to overcome a lot within
themselves yeah there's resolution that
they desire so much and you get to know
the villains a little bit too like it it
this there's at least a motion at play
here which adds to the laughter too you
know mmhmm yeah definitely and you know
like I said it's not a comedy cuz the
movie sort of has this weird tone where
it jumps back and forth between like
gritty western violence and then like
goofy comedy yea yea though this [ __ ]
will get crazy sometimes yeah I mean
there's cannibal as a minute suburbia in
pull you don't simple I do you see like
this shadow okay yeah well you don't you
don't actually it's not like a zombie
movie that would never would expect it
and knowing that i did i know that was
darker than I was expecting them to go I
was like this is a pg-13 that pg-13 has
been stretching out lately reason to see
number for fun western action did
actions a total blast my favorite
moments for a room when the action
scenes are going on it's like watching
an old school western but like
heightened yeah I got some crazy
shots in there too like is that one
crazy shower the guy gets thrown through
two windows and it's just following him
from the fall yeah do it that was
awesome there's one thing Gore Verbinski
can do it's action scenes I mean it does
feel just like a really big shiny
Western it still feels like a Western
you know while we're on this topic I got
acknowledged I don't think a lot of
people get what this movie is supposed
to be like cuz Rotten Tomatoes this has
a 23-percent or something like that or
swing which it's me it's much better
than twenty three percent yeah like I I
think it is too that's my point is like
I read a lot of the capsules at least
and I was going um what woody what is
this person talking about they're like
this movie doesn't know what it wants to
be I'm like I think the movie knew
exactly what I wanted to be I think I
want her to have some of that you know
quirkiness to it but also you know not
take itself as just a comedy in the joke
the whole time and then at the same time
two people are seeing it's bombarded
with action no it's not yeah hearing
that I went in expecting it to be like
oh it's just gonna be shootout after
shootout in big CGI train crash after
big cai train crap so I've watered a
woman [ __ ] and explosions and explosions
that is really not that thing reason to
see number five the production design uh
yeah um it looked really good it looks
great it seems like they really went out
to these big sprawling landscapes yeah
the costumes are not sold the design
data set designs are really cool yeah
everything the production locations were
awesome like like there are some
sweeping shots where you're like wow
that is real there's nothing belt there
do they have really good makeup too I
did not recognize old Johnny Depp I'm
not ruining anything for you isn't it
like narrating the move reason to see
number six the supporting cast I'll talk
about the standouts like Barry Pepper
stands out yeah Barry Pepper um who else
was here that was pretty damn I mean we
talked about him a second ago William
Fichtner who's always yeah William
Fichtner he oh yeah he was probably the
most yeah that was the one that really
stood out yeah we morphed into that role
huh yeah you forget they are watching
this guy here you've seen play a normal
person so many times yeah he really does
morph into the room ya know he showed up
and I was like oh wait like
few minutes I was like that's William
Fink oh god like he's a damn good actor
nasty and there's some good acting in
this [ __ ] movie man Barry Pepper
barely in the movie he's not an inner
ton but he he's always going scenes he
has that's some good acting yeah battle
of barry pepper what decisions were Ryan
and Jerry don't agree oh no it's kind of
boring no I agree with that no yeah i
was watching this movie and I don't know
how to explain it to you just some
scenes are kind of like there's a lack
of emotional connection I felt that this
movie could have had better with its
audience I felt they could have
connected stronger with its audience
like it does a fine job for me to say
it's entertaining and go ahead check it
out I had times you know like there's a
good side safe for me like twenty to
thirty percent where I was really just
bored I just wasn't interested in stuff
Shannon I didn't feel that way for most
of the movie I was a little I was a
little bored towards the beginning like
it took me a while to get into the movie
but yeah definitely once I settled into
the movie though I was pretty much there
the whole time and once I got used to
you know at the beginning I was like oh
this might be a long two and a half
hours and then when I finally got into
it it didn't feel like a long time yeah
yeah so maybe at the beginning but I the
rest of the time I was you know pulling
out with it you know I was having a good
time so well I guess we disagree that's
exactly why we have this category's what
decisions where Ryan and Jerry don't
agree yeah and now you understand I mean
we can fight about it to make it more
entertaining for you but I guess we just
understand what each other this is what
happens when two good friends don't
agree but they both understand what yeah
does it always have to fight Ryan's
consensus there are enough entertaining
reasons to see The Lone Ranger there are
not been searched any reasons to see The
Lone Ranger oh yeah I recommend watching
the movie i remember when i first read
the screenplay for the lone ranger
halfway through the script I realized
I'm reading a script Jerry's consensus
there are more reasons to see The Lone
Ranger than I thought there would be
there are more reasons to see the world
Ranger than Jerry thought there would be
I went in with to this movie hero all
everybody basically hating it and I had
a good time you know I it's a it's you
know a big expensive summer blockbuster
but it's a fun Western you know action
some humor had a good time I enjoyed
myself some cannibalism there is a
little cannibalism there but I wasn't
expecting she's back in the kid around
maybe done a woman around maybe don't
take your kid you know don't bring a
baby like like the people in our
audience did alright guys thanks for
checking out our show why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell us did you see the Lone Ranger and
what did you think of the goddamn thing
and once you're done with that once you
get that out of the way if you want to
check out more episodes of reasons to
see it click this link right here and
once you're done with that and you want
to get all that done and completed and
out of the way go ahead and click on
this link right here to like us on
facebook and click on this link right
here to tweet us yeah we'll follow you
back [ __ ] yeah and then once all
that's out of the way once you've
commented below checked out more reasons
to see subscribe to our facebook and our
twitter page if you want to get updated
uh-huh every time a new reviewer video
is out subscribe subscribe subscribe
yeah subscribe to everything else to it
before you subscribe to us let's to make
sure you want to subscribe to this
channel this feels like one of those
kids shows where they give you a
checklist it's like we have to go get to
the castle how do we get there let's
look at the map I don't know what this
came in mind but there's a someone who
posted on a video of ours that they
would ride Jerry's [ __ ] what and um
awesome real comment yeah and I think um
I think we need more comments like that
and to that person to that person why
won't you ride my [ __ ]
I don't get it was it a was it a dude or
chick I don't know good i mean i don't
want to insult the person but well no I
mean it was a girl maybe she's just seen
your show a lot and assume that you were
not of that persuasion what do you mean
I'll come off like I'm into chicks are
saying you talk a lot about sucking
people's dicks well there's just a few
people's dicks that I would sucks simple
as that a lot of people yeah couples
sometimes have like the list of people
you know like you're a lot of sleep with
I have a list of dicks I'm a lot of suck
Ryan Gosling Henry Cavill the Mandarin
from iron man 3 like who else it's
happened like in some work Channing
Tatum it's at least four yeah like Will
Smith did I have Will Smith I don't know
if you have low Smith actually you might
not have ok I will never say I will suck
Mel Gibson's dick ya know cuz he would
probably like get mad and then call you
up and ele
you